hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from the European Team
Championship it is aeran versus Croatia
and this is a game from board four it's
n abaso versus Marin bosio and I first
started watching board one where sharich
was playing against rajabov and that
game uh was almost almost uh ready to
explode and and just be over very
quickly but then it calmed down and then
this one ended very abruptly so ninj
abaso one of the members of the FED
candidates tournament 2024 if you
remember not so long ago he won fourth
place in the Fay World Cup um behind
Magnus CR and Fabiano corana and panand
but as Magnus Carlson will not be
playing in the candidates tournament net
abasov is set to take his place uh and
he's facing Marin
bosio 2017 Croatian Champion uh with the
black pieces so let's check it out quite
a quite a wild game uh you guys will
enjoy this one n opens with E4 we have
C6 moding goes for the caroan defense
Knight F3 we have PA Pawn to D5 and D3
uh we have Queen to C7 and now Knight to
C3 D captures on e4 Knight captures on
e4 uh and now Knight to F6 we have Queen
to E2 and now Knight captures on e4
Queen Capt and Bishop to E6 we have Pawn
to C4 and now Knight to D7 so looks a
bit odd but uh Marin obviously prepared
very well here as n already played this
against Leon menona this year in the uh
Baku uh Baku open and uh menona won that
tournament so he played a very nice game
but their game there ended in a draw
where the game continued with Knight to
G5 but here uh we have Bishop to E2
which is very interesting as Bishop to
D2 is the top move recommended by the
engine so it's hard to say what n had in
mind here but okay bishop to2 and it is
not as of move nine that we have a
completely new game we have Knight to F6
going for the queen here Queen to E3 and
now Bishop to F5 five we have Bishop to
D2 and now Pawn to E6 we have Bishop to
C3 uh and Bishop to D6 now Knight to E5
and now castles Pawn to F4 so okay
nothing um odd still happening we have
Pawn to B5 and now Pawn to G4 n just
starts his attack on the king side
Bishop to G6 and now Pawn to H4
preparing Pawn to H5 so Marin of course
plays that himself G captures on H5
Knight captures and now Pawn to C5
forcing the bishop to move back or to
capture on E5 but minin decides to go
back and now we have queenside castles
now interestingly Rook to G1 is
uh uh sorry about that Rook to G1 is
absolutely crushing here for white point
is that you don't have a good Square for
the bishop here there's just no no uh
Square you cannot move the bishop
because the Knight on H5 hangs and if
you go for something like B4 which is
the top move recommended by the engine
sort of a Counterattack with the bishop
captur and Knight to F6 it's still
insufficient Pawn to H5 and now after
the bishop moves you will play Queen G3
you threaten Checkmate and okay you can
defend with Knight A8 uh but Black's
position is already uh very very bad you
will play D4 the bishop will come to C3
you will assume this diagonal you will
Castle Queens side uh and so on uh but
he decided to Castle Queen side first
safety first and then he will go for the
attack but this allows minin to uh set
up his pieces um a bit more precisely we
have Rook D to G1 and now Pawn to B4 but
now the same idea no longer works
because if you play Bishop captures then
comes Knight captures on F4 and after
Knight captures on G6 you will play F
captures on G6 and this is um well
everything's defended the Knight is
defended the pawn on E6 is defended if
anything black will be even better here
so instead Bishop to D4 was played by
neat uh and now we have Rook a to d8 we
have Rook to G5 by nja and now Martin
played Rook to D5 uh there there is a
very nice line here with Knight captures
on F4 but seems a bit tricky to to spot
Knight captures on F4 and after Queen
captures now Rook captures on D4
attacking the queen and after Queen
captures Bishop F5 disconnects the
rook's defense of the Knight here and
the Knight cannot really move so you
will collect material now and the best
white has is something like Queen D6 you
will trade here pick up the Knight here
and okay white is up the exchange but
black is up a pawn has the bishop pair
and if anyone will be playing for the
win here will be black uh but okay
Martin went for Rook to D5 he prepares
to double up on the D file and now we
reach the critical position where net is
completely winning but uh uh it would be
I mean it would be weird for someone to
see why this is winning but you guys now
know that it's winning so you will tell
me why it's winning I'm not going to ask
you why it's winning right uh right away
uh because you can see of course that
the Knight on H5 is hanging but it's
very very tricky look at this uh ner
played Pawn to B3 here he was uh he was
expecting Marin to play Pawn to B3 which
would force him to mess up his Pawn
structure on the queen side uh but uh
the reason why this is very strong is
that after captures captures and
captures Rook F to d8 now you have to
see what uh is the winning move for
white and this is what was tricky and
why n missed it in the game so feel free
to pause the video and win the game for
white while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it if you if you spot this one you truly
are an amazing chess player and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Rook to G1 uh this is the
winning move and the what black really
doesn't have anything better than to
capture the bishop here there there
there's really nothing and after Bishop
is captured on D4 then comes Knight to
G6 absolutely disgusting move
threatening Rook to H Checkmate your
only move is to capture the Knight and
after F captures now you capture with
the queen and after Queen to F7 of
course now comes Rook to h8 with check
deflecting the king from the defense of
the queen you pick up the queen and now
your position is winning so that's how
you do it after Rook to D5 and yeah I
mean of course everyone would just play
Bishop captures on H5 uh because uh it
it does seem like you it's something
that you should play but uh B3 is what n
played sort of improving the position
saying I'm going to play this next but
now Martin plays Rook F to d8 and now
you can no longer uh play play it so
here he moves the bishop back Bishop to
B2 now again threatening Bishop captures
on H5 but now Bishop captures on E5 and
the only way to continue this is to play
Bishop captures on E5 and I will show it
because it's important uh Queen A5 and
now this will uh unwind in a draw for
example Rook to D1 Rook will capture
Bishop on E5 and after F captures you
will play Queen captures on A2 and now
you will have sufficient um uh checks to
to achieve a Perpetual for example
Bishop captures on H5 you just start
checking Queen A3 check King to C2 Queen
to A2 with check King to C1 Queen A3
check and of course you cannot go to D2
because then the D3 Pawn is not guarded
by The Rook on D1 and you might run into
problems uh however after Bishop
captures on E5 Bishop captures on E5 was
not played instead Rook captures on E5
was played and now Martin is completely
winning so again feel free to pause the
video but now win the game for Martin
while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on on This
brilliant maneuver and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is a
rook captus on D4 that's the move you
have to move with Tempo to attack the
White Queen and after Bishop captures on
D3 you go after the queen again Rook
captures on D3 Queen to E1 was played
and now Pawn to F6 asking The Rook to
move politely because then Queen
captures an F4 check will win the game
as the bishop here controls this
diagonal so you cannot do that pawn to
F5 was played uh but now comes e
captures on F5 it was again a nice trick
by n if Bishop captures he would play
Rook captures and if he captures then
Queen to E8 with check picks up the
Knight on H5 but um of course Martin
will not fall for that he just played e
captures um
uh on F5 and now there's not all that
much you can do Rook to E7 was played
now comes Queen to F4 with check and the
King hunt on for the white king begins
King to B1 and now Queen G4 preparing to
move this Pawn to open up this diagonal
King to A1 unpinning and now Pawn to F4
if nothing it's still a pass Pawn a very
strong one Rook to F1 and now Pawn to F3
we have Rook to G1 attacking the queen
queen F5 uh helping out with the
advancement of of the pawn queen F2
blocking and now Queen to D5 uh we have
Rook to C1 and now Rook to D2 chasing
the queen away Queen G1 now King to H7
and he was in this position un move 36
that n abasov resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here he had
uh some 13 minutes on the clock and four
more moves uh should have been made to
reach time control uh but there's no
point one way the game might continue
after this King to H7 move is okay you
could play something let's say Rook to E
three uh then comes Rook captures and B2
even this is in in the in the tactics
that are possible King captures now
Queen to D2 with check it seems that the
White Queen is defending both Rooks but
not really after the king moves you will
play Pawn to F2 and now after Queen to
D1 uh you will simply pick up the Rook
on E3 and that's all there is if A3 you
can even give up this Pawn although a
very very strong Pawn you can give it up
you can even bring a rook doesn't really
matter let's say queen captures now we
will play Queen captures on B3 threaten
Checkmate here as the bishop covers the
B1 square and okay you could defend
let's say queen A6 Queen E3 you will put
pressure on The Rook Rook B1 Queen to D4
with check King A2 and now Bishop F7
with check and that's it now you have to
start giving up material Bishop captures
with check King captures Queen to C3
with check King A2 B3 check King to a B1
Queen to C2 check King A1 and queen to
A2 will be Checkmate okay this is only
one of the possibilities but um pretty
much every wins here and nja did not
want to test out if Marin will be able
to be precise um uh after this King to
H7 move uh so yeah very very complicated
game as uh as um Man games usually are
he he loves attacking chess and here he
showed just how how well he does in
complicated positions and yeah here in
this position after uh this um uh well
in many positions neit was winning but
especially uh in that really tricky one
that that we've mentioned uh really not
a lot to uh say about this here after B3
was played so it's so amazing that such
positions even exist where you have
Bishop captures on H5 and you don't play
it and it's uh sometimes I say is like
you have to be an incredibly strong
player not to play Bishop captures on H5
because let's face it you have this
position I have this position your uncle
has this position we all Play Bishop
captures on H5 and is the top move
recommended by the engine but uh a fay a
you know a member of the Fay candidates
tournament 2024 is strong enough to you
know Miss Mi miss this move and not play
it he he wanted to improve the position
first and then it was all Martin after
that so yeah really really incredible
and let me just check before end the
video how is um uh how is crotia doing
so far in the event uh will I be doing
the the other game okay so still only
only this game finished the other games
are still being played martinov Drew
against mammadov uh we'll see what
happens in the other games uh but yeah
very nicely done by Martin big
congratulations on this win definitely
welld deserved one I would like to thank
Kevin Clark Camilo hea Schwarz Randall
ingol Stefan rovic and Andreas rosenal
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the uh European Team
Championship until it finishes
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day